[Musique]
http de poids cela slash bonjour
bienvenue dans fast food le journaux des
réseaux social au sommaire de cette
édition une nouvelle tendance qui émerge
sur à ce bouquet l'invité du jour un
véritable mystère d internet mais on
commence comme chaque semaine avec le
truite de la semaine qui est signée
rodrigues perez qui nous dit si mon sexe
c'était une barre de métro je ne vendrai
pas tous les jours au vu de certaines
manucure ou le comprend passons tout de
suite à notre premier sujet concernant à
ce bouquet pour nous en parler et bien
c'est gilles manouche qui est avec nous
alors gilles qu'est ce que vous faites
bonjour et bien tout le monde connaît le
baby sitting ou même aujourd'hui le dog
sitting mais quand vous partez en
vacances il ya quelqu'un dont on doit
s'occuper aussi et auxquelles on ne
pense pas souvent qui est-ce qui s il s
est lui c'est à ce book la société
s'occupe de votre âge book quand vous
n'êtes pas là on s'engage à déconnecter
reconnecter votre compte au moins trois
fois par jour pour décourager les
voleurs de compte justement incroyable
ça c'est vraiment malin alors comment
s'appelle votre service c'est l'alliance
de haas book et des baby sitting ouf le
hc thing
le sitting mais est ce que ce n'est pas
justement s'asseoir sur le visage de
votre
wii bon effectivement au moment où on a
trouvé le nom est assez bien tu as à
perdre et un ami qui nous le dit mais
bon le voile il en avait déjà acheté le
point comme on avait déjà sorti à l'inpi
alors on s'est dit qu'on allait sûrement
en parler à mon beau-frère qui n'est pas
[Musique]
société et je ne parle pas du fromage
attaque blague même si certains vont en
faire un de freinage en tout cas moi je
n'ai pas de proue société un véritable
mystère d internet ils fleurissent un
peu partout sur les réseaux social et on
ne connaît pas leurs origines ce sont
les osef après une enquête haletante
notre équipe a réussi à trouver l'auteur
de ce fameux osef il est là pour nous en
parler c'est nicolas futre alors nicolas
pour que les téléspectateurs comprennent
bien de quoi il s'agit on va essayer de
rappeler comment vous créer ces fameux
osef vous allez d'abord sur internet
regarder une vidéo ou un article vous
créez un compte vous vous y connecter
pour laisser finalement le message on
s'en fou qui en langage internet écrit
aux fds à joseph
joseph
staline
très bien
merci nicolas c'est la fin de ce fast
food le journaux des réseaux social
n'oubliez surtout pas de follow de ff
gardien
effet fast food
odette l'ami des ratons laveurs
ma famille
[Musique]
bon